[MUSIC PLAYING]
TRAVIS KALANICK: Uber is
everyone's private driver.
So get out your
smartphone, push a button,
and in just a couple minutes
a car arrives and takes you
wherever you want to go.
Taking the physical analog world
and turning it into digital
is really, really interesting,
And turning the digital world
into physical, where you're
pushing a button and a car
moves also has its challenges.
We like to say
Uber, at its core,
is sort of atoms
and bits, right?
Or maybe sometimes we
say bits and asphalt.
And where a lot of the
interesting technology
we have and interesting
operations we have
is in translating those bits
into atoms or vice versa.
First, you have to have taste.
You to know what it is you want.
But then you have to be
incredibly fierce to make sure
that a company of hundreds or
sometimes thousands of people
doesn't start taking the
vision off of the tracks.
I mean, everybody means well,
but there are so many ideas,
and you have to refine
into the best ones.
And there has to be a
product vision behind it.
And there has to be
a strong aesthetic.
And then you have to just
be hard core sometimes.
You have to be fierce
and you have to say no.